former Dance Moms star Abby Lee Miller
yes she's got less than two weeks check
in to federal prison before July 12
she's serving her year and a day
sentence for bankruptcy fraud and Nancy
you know each time that we have talked
to Abby about this
she's been riddled with fear that's a
huge dark cloud that hangs over my head
every minute of every day it's the
unknown
Abby is taking her new reality one day
at a time I catch myself getting into a
funk and going to a place that is dark
and sad
we spoke exclusively to the 50 year old
just before she was sentenced this
spring getting ready to save your pants
Abby quit Dance Moms via social media
back in March and her once thriving la
dance studio is now a police a source
close to the star tells et that quote
Abby is understandably nervous and is
anxious to put this all behind her et
has also learned that she has filmed a
new lifetime special documenting her
days before heading to jail there are
some reality stars who have spent time
in jail and Teresa Giudice one of them
do you look at her have you reached out
to her I have not I heard that she has
told some real horror stories about her
time and I don't want to look at that
look she's scared there's a lot of
rattled nerves there